marianne khedija docteur en psychologie
clinique et psychothérapeute bon soit un
mariage et bien merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france le confinement
est il pour beaucoup une épreuve
psychologique et quelles peuvent en être
les conséquences autres alors déjà la
première chose que je voudrais signaler
c'est que effectivement c'est une
période qui est pas facile qui demande
beaucoup d'adaptation et qui est
stressante
ça dépend évidemment nos conditions de
vie est ce qu'on travaille à ce qu'on
est seul en chine et est ce qu'on est
avec des enfants
voilà beaucoup de paramètres qui vont
montrer en ligne de pente
mais en soi c'est pas une une épreuve
traumato gêne c'est pas une épreuve
traumatisante
parce qu'on n'est pas si on n'est pas
exposé au virus soit mais non pas dans
des conditions extrêmement grave sur le
plan de la santé
on n'est pas exposé à un risque de mort
personnel donc ça ne risque pas de
générer des traumatismes juste parce
qu'on est confiné les risques c'est bien
sûr l'ennui et l'agacement qui peuvent
être liés à nos conditions de vie
évidemment
et donc si ça se prolonge pour
nativement le montant ça peut emmener
sur des terrains anxieux ou des terrains
dépressif et notamment si on a des
antécédents de ce type là bien sûr ça va
être un facteur de vulnérabilité
alors vous disiez ça dépend évidemment
ça semble logique évidemment le logement
selon qu'on travaille ou non avec des
enfants ça veut dire clairement où nous
ne sommes pas tous égaux notamment
peut-être préparé dans sa tête à vivre
ce confinement ne sommes pas tous égaux
à le vivre de la même manière les
conditions font que la situation est
plus ou moins stressant pour chacun
d'entre nous et puis après on a aussi
évidemment des caractéristiques
personnelles qu'ils font qu'on est plus
ou moins flexibles aux changements plus
ou moins adaptable
les personnes qui ont un grand besoin de
contrôle qui sont montés côté
psychologique et un petit peu plus
rigide vont avoir plus de difficultés à
s'adapter
alors cet été on vous dit vous dites
capacités au changement ou non
changement parce que l'envié peut être
assez redoutable chez certains d'entre
nous n'est ce pas oui non oui ça peut
être difficile après ça c'est pour le
coup pas quelque chose de très très
compliqué à occuper parce que finalement
on peut on peut trouver des occupations
selon les loisirs qu'on apprécie la
plupart d'entre nous avons quand même
accès à internet au moins dans une
certaine mesure à la télévision il peut
y avoir des tas d'autres loisirs non
connectés qui sont tout à fait
accessible donc l'ennui en fait c'est un
paramètre qui est vraiment important
pour notamment par glisser sur le
terrain de la dépression et pour ça le
meilleur conseil qu'on peut donner c'est
d'essayer de calais des activités avoir
un planning en fait dans la journée même
si sur le fond on n'aurait pas besoin de
planning mais essayer vraiment de se
fixer dans la journée des temps où on va
être occupée et puis détendant nuit
c'est pas en soi un problème on peut
avoir des temps ils sont nécessairement
déprimé alors vous parlez de la question
des enfants ça concerne évidemment
beaucoup de français on se fait voilà
qu'on joue un petit peu les rôles de
professeurs avec les enfants quel est
l'avis de la psychologue là dessus et
sous c'est plus facile finalement selon
vous de vivre en confinement avec des
enfants ou plus difficile où ça dépend
des cartes
évidemment ça va dépendre des cas je
pense que c'est pas simple c'est très
difficile de concilier éventuellement
vie professionnelle enseignement de ce
pourquoi tout le monde
n'est pas d'ailleurs compétents c'est
assez frustrant de combiner tout c'est
toutes ces casquettes en même temps donc
les parents je pense sont assez stressés
ça dépend aussi bien entendu de l'âge
des enfants
et puis leur tempérament aussi voilà
après je vais vous sortir le classique
du petit qui essaye de relativiser c'est
un moment de découverte profitons-en
pour passer du temps de qualité avec nos
enfants
quels sont les conseils justement aux
parents désespérés on voit certaines
petite parodie assez régulière sur
internet
manifestement il ya beaucoup de parents
qui voient là qu'ils sont un petit peu
sous pression quels sont les conseils
que vous donneriez alors les conseils
ils vont être les mêmes pour les parents
et pour les enfants c'est d'essayer et
je sais que c'est pas simple mais
d'essayer de cadrer au temps possible
dans la journée détente différencié pour
donner des repères aux enfants essayé de
respecter bien sûr les repères liés à
l'alimentation ou couché tous les
repères classiques où on peut voir
commentaire par exemple pendant les
temps de vacances mais elle a essayé de
les maintenir
et puis ne pas hésité à impliquer les
enfants dans des tâches de la maison eux
ça les valorise ça leur donne un petit
peu de contrôle aussi par exemple faire
la cuisine et des pour le ménage des
choses comme ça voilà c'était petites
choses il faut vraiment essayer
d'impliquer les enfants et leur signifie
aussi que il ya des espaces et des temps
pour les parents où ils sont pas
forcément tout le temps les bienvenus
ils doivent respecter une certaine
intimité pour les parents les vacances
puisqu'on est en vacances il ya pas
beaucoup de différence ça peut
occasionner chez heures petit frère sur
ya moins de devoir peut-être moins de
deux structures l'appel évidemment des
écrans aux cadets la vie de l'apli
là-dessus alors les écrans évidemment on
sait que c'est un facteur de risque pour
les enfants un petit peu d'écrans c'est
possible ça dépend usage il faut ajuster
évidemment en ce moment je pense que la
plupart des parents sur une augmentation
du temps d'écran pour avoir un petit peu
plus de temps tranquille de leur côté il
faut quand même essayer d'y faire
attention parce que souvent on va on va
payer le retour de bâton un petit peu
plus tard
avec des enfants qui vont être plus
excités moins attentifs et puis quand il
vend quand il va falloir essayer de
reprendre l'école ça va ça va être
compliqué donc il faut faire attention à
limiter les écrans les enfants peut se
divertir aussi autrement qu'avec une
tablette on en revient à cette fameuse
stratégie de déconfinement on a entendu
edouard philippe nous donner aucune
durée nous dire que ça va justement
durée mais sans perspective de fin est
ce que ça c'est bon pour le moral est ce
que c'est pas justement l'un des
facteurs peut être les plus stressants
pour l'être humain de ne pas savoir de
ne pas avoir de perspective
oui je pense qu'effectivement c'est
stressant après le stress on n'en mesure
pas non plus quand il reste dans des
proportions limitées donc
malheureusement là on peut pas avoir
d'indications plus précises mme la
stratégie que je conseillerai c'est
d'essayer de voir un petit peu loin
c'est-à-dire à -3 4 semaines en espérant
qu'ils aient pas de déception d'ici là
mais vraiment il faut partir sur le
principe que il va falloir s'ajuster à
cette situation encore pour un moment
il essayait de planifier aussi loin que
possible une autre mauvaise nouvelle en
tout cas pour les sportifs qui ont
peut-être besoin de soupape de
décompression l'activité sportive
interdit désormais à paris alors c'est
un peu la double panne tri j'ose dire
parce que ce sont souvent les personnes
qui habitent dans des appartements qui
n'ont pas de deux maisons avec des
jardins est ce que selon vous c'est une
bonne mesure
alors moi ce que j'ai compris c'est pas
que c'était interdit c'est que ce serait
dur à 19 heures enfin voilà c'est pas
interdit complètement ça laisse quand
même des plages horaires importante le
matin et le soir pour le faire et
effectivement l'activité physique quelle
qu'elle soit c'est pas forcément du
footing on peut aussi faire du de
l'actif physique l'activité physique à
domicile mais l'activité physique c'est
une très bonne pratique en période de
stress parce que quand on est stressé on
va sécréter des hormones qui vont
s'accumuler dans le corps étendre nos
muscles
donc effectivement pouvoir décharger
énergie là d'une façon saine c'est ça
permet vraiment apaiser les tensions
quels sont justement les autres
palliatifs faire de la gym devant sa
télé peut-être de la méditation il ya
des conseils sur chopin oui la
méditation la cuisine tout ce qui va
vous distrait en fait tout ce qui va
vous relaxer elle il ya plein de
techniques de relaxation qu'il
fonctionne bien aussi des activités
sportives plus ou moins tendre le
pilates et cetera
occupez vous essayez de faim et l'idée
c'est vraiment de ne pas partir sur
j'attends que le temps passe parce que
si vous faites ça clairement ça va être
déprimant donc c'est plutôt essayer de
rythme et ses journées avec des
activités un peu régulières à des
horaires a qui ont du sens ce peut-être
de faire la même chose tous les mardis
tous les mercredis voilà d'essayer de
créer des moutis n'ont fait qu'ils vont
redonner un rythme à une semaine qui
pourrait paraître extrêmement au notw
donc on va tous finir grands cuisiniers
merci marc ian kelly à docteur en
psychologie clinique et psychothérapeute
remercier d'avoir été avec nous